[Applauso]
milanese ed è stato scritto da un
personaggio molto legato a esino michele
vedani grande scultore di cui possiamo
ammirare la splendida via crucis sul
viale che porta alla chiesa e il pezzo
si intitola anno 1900 vivida e il making
paesi isin è una villeggiatura de
montanea del sura de varenne a sul milan
e per circa che si guadagnano con sette
chilometri da rampa si la strada nella
terra oppure in slitta o sul web e jean
a allora le era l'unica strada per
andare xi il tuca aveva invita paesi e
il mac linea the pin perché pochi di
cahill poteva dispongo d'accordo e
trovasse a varenna allora combinata le
riva tc che stringi sfida un bel vesti
marocco e call sua campana scarpette
vernissage perché pare vende tola con
tukul et che si usava lura alt come il
col
questo dopo un team piega che girante il
collo se faceva fatica perché sgarbo
lava bisognava che il tennis la testa
dritta come se il gallese sporta col
contuna cravattari cruz e blake un punta
dentro una spilla d'oro fa da punto ed
interrogazioni tempestava de pietri cruz
de veder rifiuti sipri a consorti barbie
city con la punta di sa come di fil de
fer silk un card en el contuna lobbia
alta a kassir e la colorata ad un
maruschin stimava e seguitava domanda se
stava bene e se ghe piase vi queste
pudiche sauvé stilerà neve e il gaveva
più si spalle sacchet denti la colorata
con dente re necessari de cambiasse
adesso m penser l'era o per la slitta
opere
l'unica slitta le rock you padre da una
shura tempah da con si un capelli
the rent alcu con di piccone fioriti che
pareva in in pasta succhi poker e grace
hall un rene khrin jala decisi per il
perché up e con chi scarpette de verni
sisters e saresti vaizey nappe di 8
hai un chip e senza salva e scarpe e lui
era una femmina alta col busted elenchi
a vedere le ricordava il don chisciotte
della mancia anche me faceva paura sia
quella altezza e parevo movimento
equester mai viste e il che aveva prima
una sveglia che l'aveva levata dal suo
sacchetto made it che l'era per
svegliarsi alla mattina
l'altra manera salda sui pasti pronti a
luras in cammino ma fa il 7 km de salida
lei era la strada che facevi semper
tutti i sabati cui soli trenta chili
circa sui spal per la mia famiglia
perché aesi fiera del latte ed iter
luger alter l'era una giornata britta
propri brit ha annullate e se ci ama
mattoni un uomo teaser lot e su biava un
troupe de pianta di qetta stringe crytek
al sun l'artic pesa tratti la fee spagna
dell'it la russa il mare che arrivare
nappi è fissata italo lister chissà da
quanti anni con profili mantic destare
il gaveva stupore rommel basse tester
anche l'usa riuscirsi all'altezza del
stomi la faccia culure quadrelle vecchi
tanto sport che credi che si lavava
quanto e pioveva e che il dormiva sempre
vesti di grease paventa come una
scimmietta con l'orlo rus vive il nas
keyshia con la punta a ciresa la bocca
grande hacker it center cadei e barba
spunto una tra grisales purché quante
parlava el trafugava di parole che
spirava ferro con tanta bari cioè e il b
tav ha perforato i denti incisivi già al
che balla ven h sfida di field gengiva e
il cappello tung come una tazzina
impastata sul cumulato aic d'orecchi che
pareva i nostri mega è il capello pesant
di un tweet cras tra perde salam ecotec
dell'arta run sciita come diceva la
giornata l'errata un tool brita negrini
un cure vena galoppa il chelsea scriva e
il dente l'era four pensavi al maine che
e me la sastri vario aisin prima che il
più s
se era un circa metà strada e mclean
seguitava lamenta scala mila
l'asta troppi neri va della mia terra e
usava e il gap eva ha paura definì la
val con la mela ma il tono è che
rispondeva bauchant che le andava jolly
ma la mia mila no è il mac linea è il
gad manda alto come si chiama la sua
milan ma si chiama teresa l'air al non
della mia povera mie per ricordarla n
quindi allegati che le ha un bel ricordo
è la giornata in cig ramallah me mai
capita da curve incominciava il burro
mutamenti al temporale carichi denim e
la cui parlava il dentro imperversava
furious elton al m a elga miss sul qe il
folder di un sacco a dio boom beta anche
alla shura sulla slitta un attila sulla
cooper si eyes of fury già in patacca e
una t la sil venter impermeabile che il
melate pampers e fumava la furbetta
d'acqua e che alzava latina e senza
sapere che la fava andato il venter
ma cosa fa la che di sla shura me bagna
chiude denter lisci camminavo misto
silenzi di lourdes è sentito un ipad mi
impedì alla mela e frec astrid ul della
slip ei ave maria che seguitava recita
la sciura in la slitta una bella si
usuri e mi vedevi il macchina tweet
fasci lamela che parlava più con la
sveglia indù lama e l'altra franca dal
basti nessun senti strangola la culex
tommy de comunione dei santi incolpevoli
da me li invita le vene infine il mago
un contu struss un the man kamel via
tisci tre ave maria dell'ashura il free
cast di fer della mila altri di lahm
della slitta e il cielo e le mandava già
tanta acqua che l'amiu laterale radi
verità down to rain è già trovate
stralis che eliminava e la val chemie
fava vede l'ombra del maine isernia che
il pareva un fantasma finalmente dopo
tanto spaventa il temporale hills è
calma e da pupo ctim sen riva jesi ma in
macchina sempre raggomitolarsi lamela
parlava più
pareva un sacco di carbone bagnato la
villa si arriva la scala la mila la
infila sui villa porta
questa era tanto bassa e media e se
trova impastarsi la porta della spa la
cayman silver sbragia andato a busto
resa teresa dalla sun dà la sveglia
intera e il toni e il tirava la cua per
la vela e teresa è il tono è seguita ma
teresa ferme sperber male rapisce
berisha che parole finalmente tira il
messaggio della milan el pareva
imbalsama impe qui campano avverte il
pareva una statua dei cartoon né sforzi
a di comete state pepi senza parlarle
burla intera in tre contro almir della
scala la bottiglia il cui addio
cardarelli e se schiacciate in cure e
chalmers a faccia
chissà anche al sacchetto che però è la
ripara buell culp le mission gabel ott
dopo un po mater b e c è ma guarda in
faccia e cultura
ma dovete memena e si è ripreso un po la
der veer sa che to treat bagnadentro un
impasto tra mangi de nard e camisa bird
e amit su presa insieme a una torta con
tanti color defluita cota una poltiglia
una puccia cadere gordana tavolozza di
pittura sguazza guarda con comunue la
sveglia col vestino effettuato asta
mercanzia riina della dita ecco tutto il
messaggio di montagna e per la ditta ma
cossu fa tema
[Applauso]